hey guys Ryan right here be crazy so I'm
a little sick right now
I got body aches got a little bit of a
cough and I feel weak and miserable but
I know none of that matters to you guys
is you guys just want a [ __ ] video to
come up every day
ha ha dark comedy today I never want to
warn your friends they'll never come
over today I'm gonna check out this
video with Elissa called reactors
assemble I don't really know what this
is but apparently I'm featured in it
Veronica is like non-stop work so she
couldn't be in this video today joining
us but I her she's featured in it I
don't know if your future in it but
apparently it's like a video the
reactors in the Avengers or something I
don't really know what it is yeah
everyone's been saying I gotta check
this video out
further venture
you disable come
that was the most amazing fan tribute
thing I've ever seen everyone this very
moment you better subscribe your ass to
a dick he ate it I think I would have
gone with a dick a dick the one aid D
isn't dog I K as in KKK the one as in
Gentiles the one that was dude I feel I
feel so honored to be a part of this
cuz I'll be honest like we do reactions
but I'm one of those guys who's like
yeah I know not a lot of work early goes
into reaction so I find put a lot of
work into the review part but this was
like I'm proud I do reactions this is
[ __ ] cool wow that was taking so much
time to do like wait this is wow that
was really [ __ ] cool thanks for
featuring Veronica to [ __ ] shower I
know she should just do a reaction on
her Channel
yeah yeah okay I'm sweetie a dick the
one you rock wherever you are you just
greet me at my door with your pants down
your dick hard and I will suck the [ __ ]
out of that come if you guys are new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects ELISA has a channel - ELISA
being crazy you should change it - ELISA
be crazy sauce like in and out but she
has a really good channel he's a lot of
fun she's gonna run over 70 videos on
the real rejects then you can follow us
on Facebook Instagram and Twitter
ELISA be crazy to be Orion right for the
real rejects a dick the one follow him
to follow the other reactors as well
don't follow Tyrone Magnus though he's
the worst one he's the worst
nobody likes Tyrone out of all the
reactors
he's definitely at the pump
he's everyone's favorite that has really
uplifted the feelings of the sickness
into a very positive manner I am very
grateful for that video edik the one
you've cheered me up so much I'm going
to tweet the hell out of that video
you're so awesome god a dick I just want
I want to just spread my ass cheeks over
and have you go inside of me Peter M
green hey Ryan
love your channel it's epic I look
forward to your reaction videos you
deserve a million subscribers 1 million
subscribers so tyrannous 1 million
subscriber except I make him sound like
a character from game of thrones would
like a shout-out from Peter in the buck
Luke okay UK it's not capital it's true
I know it's so hard to get Peter you
know it's funny I was the Hulk in this
and Peter stands for you know it could
also be a penis oh yeah there's that his
last name is green green penis like the
Hulk it's like this shout-out was meant
to happen and the United Kingdom right
price over there sweep your old chin
your Widow we long names green penis